and I know that you may not agree with
my opinion, but I cannot help but say
today that the use by the
United States of America in its
foreign policy of such instruments as
support for the so-called color
revolutions,
support in this regard for the coup d’etat in
Kiev in 2014, ultimately
led to today’s  Ukrainian
crisis and has additionally made a
negative contribution to the degradation of Russian-
American relations. Relations between Russia
and the United States of America, on which
global security
and stability directly depend, are experiencing deep
crises. Unfortunately, it is based on
fundamentally different approaches to
the formation of the modern world order.
Russia is open to constructive
partnership with everyone without exception.
country, we are not going to isolate ourselves from anyone, we do
not have any biased and
especially hostile intentions towards anyone